الله خلقها وزن 45 كيلو جابت اربع اولاد
صار وزنها 50 كيلو بتيجي بتسالك انت كيف
ضعفتي ليه عم تسالي ههه
قهرني اه عن جد عملتي عمليه ما كان لازم
تعملي عمليه كان مشي حالك بدايه وانه
حبيبتك انت لما بتعملي دايت تكوني بدل ما
عم تاكلي سندويشتين سندويشه واحده وبتضعفي
انا اسمي بنان الغدير عملت عمليه تكميم من
تقريبا سنه ونصف هلا انا
بعمر يعني
صغير نسبيا يعني من عمر 12 13 سنه كان
عندي شويه وزن زايد ما في شيء بالعالم ما
جربته يعني يعني من الرجيم الكيميائي
للرجيم التمر واللبن لرجيم الموز والما
بعرف شو لرجيم اللي اخذته بنت الجيران من
ما بعرف مين
ظبط وعليها وانا لا للكيتو لكل شيء للوكر
كل شيء رحت عند دايتشن اكثر من مره كل شيء
ممكن تتخيليه بهذا الموضوع انا مجربته
يعني ادويه تنحيف كمان مجربتها فاخذت قرار
من سنه ونص انه اعمل تكميم على اساس انه
حل حل جذري لهذا الموضوع لح اليوم اللي
انا يصير معي شي وتنزل نفسيتي وتنزل
معنوياتي تساعدني العمليه انه ما ارجع
لمحل صحتي فيه كتير اذا بدك
لما نزلت
على غرفه العمليات
ووصلت حسيت حالي انه انا كتير موتره
وخايفه وبدات ابكي بدات ابكي بطريقه
كتير كتير قويه فتخيلي انه انا حدا ضل
اربع سنين عم يدور على دكتور واربع سنين
عم يدرس خيارات واربع سنين لقرر انه هو
يعمل العمليه وبالاخير بس
بس وصلت لليوم وللحظه اللي بدي اعمل فيها
العمليه حسيت بشعور غمرني يعني حتى بعد
اسبوعين مثلا من العمليه وقت قصه الريكفري
وبدك تضلي تاكلي سوائل على فتره معينه
بعدين اكل مطحون بعدين كل هذا الشيء بتشوف
العالم حواليك عم تاكل بتقولي شو عملت
بحالي كيف عملتي حالي هيك يوم بتذكر كلام
بعد شي اسبوعين من العمليه
كنت
كانوا عم ياكلوا يمكن ورق عنب شي شي هيك
وانا كنت لسه عم باخذ شوربات او هيك
فانت فكرت انه انه كيف عملت بحالي هيك كيف
حرمت حالي من شيء انا بحبه وفتت وبكيت
يعني
ما رح اقول انه هو عادي مشان هيك انا ضليت
اربع سنين لحتى قررت انه انا اعمل العمليه
فاكيد مانو عادي وما بظن انه اي حدا يقرر
يعمل اي عمليه بكون الموضوع بالنسبه له
عادي ما بعرف حدا ما عمل هاي العمليه الا
مكان الموضوع ضاغط فيه وعلى نفسيته ما حدا
بفيق الصبح بيكون مبسوط ورايق وبقول يلا
خليني اعمل عمليه واتمنى وادفع مصاري
واقعد واقعد بريكفري ويفوتوا ينيموني وما
اعرف حالي راح افيق اما لا اي عمليه هي شي
كتير صعب بس اكيد انتو في ضغط بيكون فيه
عليك لحتى تعملي هالاعمليه ضغط من الناس
ضغط نفسي ضغط انت شو بتكون عم تفكري هذا
بالنهايه بيختلف من من حاله لحاله مانو شي
سهل اكيد العمليه فيها خطوره واكيد هي
المخاطر تبعها بتادي للموت بس كمان انه
يوصل مرحله انه يكون وزنه كتير عالي وما
عم يقدر يسيطر على الموضوع يا جماعه هذا
الشيء بيؤدي للموت
اول فتره بتكون الوزن عم ينزل كتير بسرعه
فانت بتكوني كتير كتير
متحمسه يعني بعدين بتصير بينزل ابطا ابطا
وهم بتصير بتقولي يا الله الله يرحم ايامك
كنت انزل كل ثلاثه اربعه كيلو سوا بس اول
فتره ايه بكون النزول كتير سريع وكثير حلو
يعني ومقاساتك بتتغير بسرعه الموضوع
العمليه مانو موضوع سهل ابدا من ناحيه كيف
حياتك عم تتغير يعني انا بتذكر انه بعد
لانه انا مثلا ضليت سنه وزني زايد قبل ما
اعمل عمليه فانا مريت بفتره
بالمول اتطلع قولي يا الله هالبنت لابسه
جينز حلو ارجع اتطلع لاقي هاي حالي والله
العظيم
فايه انت ما بتكوني متعوده على الايموجي
الجديده الجديده تبعك وما لانه انت نسيتي
حالك كيف كنتي لما كنت هيك
ايه في مثلا اشياء كتحب البسها ما كنت
اقدر البسها في اشياء ما كنت لاقي مقاساتي
في براندات معينه ايه ما كنت اقدر الاقي
مقاساتي فيها اصلا كلنا كلنا عنا بالخزانه
بتعرفيها لهنكته عنا هذا اللي بلبسه بكره
بس اضعاف
[موسيقى]
من ثيابك اللي لما كنت انت ضعيفه يا اما
من من شغلات انت اشتريتيها وما لقيتيها
زابطه او ما سكر السحاب او ما سكر الزر
وقلتي خلاص بس اضعف خمسه كيلو بسكر عليه
كثير منيح
وبس بتعرفي الخمسه كيلو يمكن اصلا ما ضعفت
الخمسه كيلو يعني بس مثلا انا كان عندي
كتير كتير شغلات قلت بكره بس اضعف بالبسه
وعملت العمليه وتخيل القهر وين انه بس
قستم بعد العمليه طلعوا كثير بشعين اكيد
ذوقك انت بيتغير ثاني شيء انت ما بتعرفي
القصه اذا رح تلبق عليك ولا لا عرفتي فقاع
اكيد كلنا بنشتري اوقات شغلات بس هلا ابدا
ما بعمل هيك
[موسيقى]
اول شيء نحن بمجتمعنا
العربي اكثر شي الاكل هي هي فعاليه عائليه
واجتماعيه فانت رقم واحد لما انت بدك
تعملي ريجيم اما دايت معين انت اوت انت
اوت من الطلعات انت اوت من اللانش بريك
تبع الشغل انت اوت بجامعات العيله لانه
انت عندك اكله
الثاني اللي لازم انت تاكليه ثاني شيء انه
جسمك انت اكيد بيتعب بعد بعد فتره معينه
يعني حتى مثلا دايت اللي انا رحت عند اكتر
من اخصائي تغذيه جربت انه انا التزم معهم
انا فيني اقول انه انا ما كنت محظوظه انه
التقى بحدا عن جد امين وبيشتغل بطريقه
صحيحه يعني بتذكر فيه انا دكتور تغذيه
مشهور انا رحت عملت عنده دايت وكنت عم
بتفعله
في كانت جارتي
وزنه وجسمه غير عني بس اكتشفت بعدين انه
اعطينا اثنيناتنا نفس الدايت يعني هي نفس
الورقه عم يتبعها للكل انه شو استفدت انا
يا جماعه الموضوع مش بهالسهوله لا من
ناحيه الاكل ولا من ناحيه انك انت تجيب
لبس رياضه يعني انا لما كان وزني 95 كيلو
بده يروح على النادي وبتروح على النادي
بصيروا بيتطلعوا فيك انه شو جايه تعمل هاي
معنا انه النادي للجميع اشتراكي فلوسي انا
دافعتهم وبدي اتبرن اتمرن فيهم وبتيجي
مثلا بتفوت على على كلاس تجي المدربه
بتكون عم تعمل 100 نقطه بالدقيقه وبتقول
لك يو كان دوت لا حبيبتي i can't i can't
لما بيكون وزنك 50 وش لما بكون وزنك
انا اعطيني تمرين ثاني اعمله غير هاد
التمرين يا اخي اعملوا صفوف للعالم اللي
وزنها وزنه زايد يعني
ما حدا بحب انه هو يكون مو صحي ما حدا بحب
يكون مو حلو اكيد ما حدا حيحب انه تكون
صحته مش منيحه او انه يكون وزنه زايد كمان
على على الجهه المقابله وكل حدا وزنه
مثالي يعني صحته منيحه في كتير عالم بتكون
ضعيفه وعندها مليون مشكله صحيه طيب هدول
العالم ما حقهم انهن يكونوا مرتبين وحلوين
ولابسين مثلهم مثل كل العالم بيطلعوا
بالمرايه بيشوفوا شي هن بحبوه بعدين بدنا
نرجع اصلا خطوه لورا مين اللي قال انه نحن
لازم كلنا يكون وزننا 55 كيلو مين اللي
اخترع هذه النظريه عن جد مين يعني مين
اللي قال انه نحن كنا لازم نلبس سمول او
ما لازم لازم نلبس اكس سمول هذا اصلا مقاس
الزيرو مين اللي اخترعه
ما انا عارف مين اللي اخترعك يعني انا هلا
بعد كل عمليه وبعد كل اللي انا عملته ما
عم بلبس سمول وما ما بظن اني راح الب س مو
اليوم من الايام بس بدنا نتقبل حالنا
ونتقبل جسمنا واصلا لحتى الشخص يشتغل على
حاله لازم يتقبل حاله فاكيد بالعكس هذا
الشيء بساعد بساعد البنات والشباب انه هن
يتقبلوا حالهم يشتغلوا على حالهم احسن
[موسيقى]
نحن عنا اطوال واحجام واشكال انف مثلا
مختلفه انه بما انك حكيتي عمليه الانف او
شفايف مختلفه
اجا هلا
الترند قال انه شكل الشفايف هذا هذا اللي
هو شكل الانف هذا هو الابروف شكل الجسم
هذا هو الابروت وانا ما عندي هذا الابروف
انت جيت قلت البنت اللي بتكون شكلها هيك
هي حلوه وحتى الشاب اللي شكله هيك هو
الحلو
بهذا الشيء
وانتم عم تتنمروا علي كل الوقت لانه انا
ما عندي هذا الشيء بس انا معي فلوس فلما
قررت انه انا بفلوسي اعمل هذا الشيء كمان
بدكم تحكموا علي شو بعمل بحالي حتى الشاب
اللي كانوا قبل بيقولوا برجال ما بعيبوا
الرجال ما بعيبه شي صارت الشباب عم تعمل
فيلر وبوتكس وهولي انت بتخيله للعالم
عايشه فيه ما بالك البنت اللي هي مطلوب
منا كل الوقت انها هي تكون حلوه
ومرتبه والعالم عم تطلع عليها انه انا
بصراحه ما بقى الوم البنات شو ما عملوا
يعني اقوى اقوى
[موسيقى]